we have a major update this morning to a
CBS News investigation about child labor
in Africa last year Debora patta exposed
the brutal conditions for children who
are mining cobalt in the Democratic
Republic of Congo now a new lawsuit
blamed some of the world's biggest tech
companies from benefiting from those
conditions which have sometimes led to
the deaths of child workers cobalt is
used in things like batteries and
products for many Americans everyday
Debora patta is in Johannesburg Deborah
what's behind this lawsuit well more
than half the world's cobalt comes from
the Democratic Republic of Congo where
the United Nations says over 40,000
children have been used to mine the
metal and in the nearly two years since
our investigation our sources on the
ground say conditions are as desperate
as ever for these children kids are
still doing the unthinkable in the DRC
that breaking work even for adults but a
world away in Washington there's new
hope for the children in a lawsuit filed
against major American tech companies
who use the cobalt the suit filed
against Apple Google Dell Microsoft and
Tesla accuses the companies of knowingly
benefiting from and aiding and abetting
the cruel and brutal use of young
children in the DRC to mine cobalt
cobalt is used in almost every
electronic device powered by batteries
from smartphones to electric cars 14
children who were injured or killed
while mining are being represented by
human rights lawyer teri Collingsworth
sperm we traced the supply chain back
from the mine where the children were
either killed or maimed and have traced
it back up to these companies the suit
calls for companies to take
responsibility for child miners and
their supply chains and change the way
they sorts the metal we contacted all
five companies for comment Apple said
they've led the industry in standards
and removed six cobalt refiners who
don't meet those standards in 2019
doll said it never knowingly sourced
operations using any form of child labor
and is currently investigating these
allegations Google Microsoft and tesslar
have not yet replied at the beginning of
2018 CBS News travel to the DRC here
children were lugging heavy sacks of
cobalt to be washed in rivers from as
early as 4:00 they were picking it out
of a pile breathing in toxic fumes
we followed a supply chain where child
mined and legally mined cobalt were not
separated we told the story of one child
11 year old Ziggy Swasey who thanks to
the generosity of our viewers was
removed from the mines and given a
chance to go to school where he is now
thriving the hope is that more children
like Ziggy can be rescued from these
mines and sent to school just this
morning we received these photos of
Ziggy celebrating Christmas with his
friends I think it's the first time I've
seen him smiling and I guess it shows
the power but shining a light on these
children can have Tony people really
stepped up for Ziggy you really felt for
him when you heard Deborah story and I'm
very glad to see him in a better
situation but I'm thinking about the
other kids that are out there you're
right absolutely